hello my name is Vernon Oliveira and I
work in the Play Games team today we're
here to talk about two of my favorite
things which are the play games API and
the NDK and how to use those to dinner
to make a game so when you're writing a
game using the play games API you
normally have to worry about connecting
all these callbacks that the Android
lifecycle gives you so we have uncrate
they have on store they have on stop on
activity result in several other
callbacks normally if you're writing a
game that's not native you can usually
get away with just subclassing
basegameactivity which is the class that
we have in the samples when you subclass
basegameactivity all that lifecycle is
connected for you now of course if
you're writing a native game as you know
you can subclass basegameactivity why
because you have to use native activity
for in it for a native game so we're
going to talk about how to setup native
activity to do exactly that so first of
all you don't have to use native
activity as it is you can actually
subclass it so this is what we do here
so before anything we start with base
game it actually native activity and
then we derive our activity class from
it so in this case our game is called
awesome game so we are deriving awesome
game activity from base gaming from from
native activity since we're going to use
the the game helper which is also in the
samples we also implement game helper
dot game helper listener which is d
which is the the listener class that
game helper uses so next we with the
clerk game helper inside of our of our
activity and we have to manage its
lifecycle remember this is actually done
by base game activity but it's not
actually very hard to do it yourself to
do this all you have to do first of all
you want to load your your game library
because it's an antique a game so reload
et the game library using systems load
library next we want to hook up the game
helper to do this for it for example
when I have on create so first of all
you create your game helper here and
then what you have to do is call game
helper like M helper set up and this is
when you do the setup for the game
helper here we're specifying that we
want the games client and we also want
the f state client and we're going to
use those in our game after you don't
create all you have to do is do the same
on start so whenever you get the on
start callback the game Hepler needs to
know that the answer has happened so
this is how you hook it up on unstop
it's pretty much
same thing so on on stop you just call
em hell produc on stop and that connects
it correctly next you'll also need on
activity result you'll do just the same
thing you're just calling helper to
notify that the result has come in
because that's necessary for that for
the whole sign-in process with the with
the dialogues and so on so you need to
get the other results to the helper next
you have to wait for the sign-in
callback so you're going to be notified
that sign-in succeeded or fails through
the sign-in callbacks like consignee
succeeded in on sign-in failed so that's
when you probably want to notify your
your native code that this onion has
succeeded or failed so next so let's
let's talk about how to do how to
actually do sign-in so first of all
we're not going to talk in into great
length about the about the J&I but you
have to initialize J&I so first of all
you can do that using attach current
thread and then you have a working
attachment to the thread that you can
use to make GI calls of course don't
forget because that I made that mistake
don't forget to detach the current
thread otherwise we're gonna get strange
crashes in the background after you're
done setting up the J&I you probably
you're you're probably gonna want to
have a sign-in button somewhere in your
game so the sign-in button
pretty much looks like that you have
some Liberty to customize it but when
the when the player clicks on it you
should start the sign-in flow so the
sign-in flow is the whole is the whole
set of dialogues that the player has to
click through to actually authorize your
game to access the play games API so
when the user clicks that what you want
to call this is a job of course you want
to call em help order begin user
initiated sign-in so that's gonna begin
the whole sign-in flow however since
you're gonna be calling it from the game
thread so remember that the game's gonna
be running on a separate thread it's not
the UI thread so you need to wrap that
with a run on a UI thread call so that
you can actually call that method from
the game thread and have it execute on
the UI thread so this is why we have
this method which is called post post
start sign in which essentially can be
called from any thread and post to the
UI thread and there we call him helper
to begin user initiated sign in now
let's show how to actually start the
flow from C++ so nobody is afraid of J
and I right so this is how we invoke we
invoke that method using j'ni it's just
standard J and I just get the the
activity object the activity class and
then we get the method ID
for for our method and then invoke it
notice that when we do that when we do
this we actually sidestep one of the
major difficulties of using j'ni in
android which is that if you just try to
find a class by a name it's not going to
find it because you can only find the
actual frame or classes using fine class
unless you do funny stuff with class
loaders so notice that we are completely
sidestepping this whole difficulty by
just using our own activity as a
starting point so we're using our own
activity and calling method that we
wrote after we call this then we get the
sign-in flow alright so after you do the
sign-in flow you have to know when
you're actually signed in so that your
game can respond to that appropriately
you're going to know that when on the
Java side you get this onsigninsucceeded
callback so that's the callback title
that tells you that sign-in has
succeeded or else that this onion has
failed so how do you actually notify the
code you have well you can to notify the
native code that this has happened what
you usually gonna have to do is to write
the native method that the Java side can
call and then notify your native code
that this happened whether one of the
ways to do this actually I think it's
pretty useful pattern it's not to have
just a boolean saying yes or no is
actually to have a three state variable
saying it's either Semyon has failed
Semyon has succeeded or sign-in is in
progress and then from native code he
can react appropriately to those states
so we're declaring these states as
constants here and then we're calling
we're also declaring a native method
from Java which is reports any result so
we're going to call that method whenever
we want to report a sign-in results or
progress to to native code so this is
how we do it so when we when we are on
on start we say that sign-in is in
progress why because every time your
application gets an on starts like comes
back from the background or anything
like that
sign-in is not ready yet so Simon is in
progress because the the play gives the
API has to reconnect it's only when you
get onsigninsucceeded after on start
that you can actually start to make a
call so whenever you get on start this
is when you report a native code that
said that the sign-in is currently in
progress then of course when you get on
stop it's the same thing you also say
that sign-in is in progress even though
it had succeeded before why because when
you get on stop a sign-in is no longer
working and
it's in progress because it's gonna come
back later then when you get on sign-in
actually when you start the sign-in
process using post starts I mean which
is the method that we just showed you
also say that it's in progress because
well the your UI flow is happening right
now and at the end of it you're gonna
get on sign it succeeded or fails next
of course when you get on Sammy
succeeded that's when you report that
the sign-in state is success when you
get on sign-in failed to report that
sign-in was a failure and then your
native code is where it's going to have
to know how to handle those states so
next how do you actually handle that
from native code it's just a j9 in a
native method so all you have to do is
write the that method signature that you
can generate with java h and then when
in that method gets called all you have
to do is react to that one caveat is
that you're going to be running on the
UI thread on that method so be careful
not to try to like manipulate your game
state and so on in a way that make lash
with your game thread so usually one of
the useful methods they're just use some
sort of synchronization or write to a
right one's variable or something
something like that but it's important
to note is that it's got to be on the UI
thread so don't do anything funny there
all right so that's pretty much all
there is for for thee for this first
episode please watch the the other ones
because then I'm gonna go more in-depth
into achievements leaderboards and to
how we can actually do this on a deeper
level thank you very much